my name is Tony boa and and I want to
talk a little bit about myself
before I get into this wonderful book
the the principle fact about me is and
and one that everybody always forgets as
they deal with the obvious questions of
my career is that I was born in Spain so
I take an immigrants perspective of this
great country of ours I came here at the
age of nine and and could see the
opportunities immediately from Spain we
were very poor my father was a coal
Stoker on a ship he died when I was
fifteen and we did the usual struggles
and and when up and I became a cop in
1953 spent 24 years in the New York City
Police Department the last four as
commanding officer of the Bronx forces
then left there and went for three years
as number two with the transit police
but as the subway police in New York
City and I spent three years there and
then was Chief of Police of Minneapolis
for nine years from 1980 to the
beginning of 89 and now we do a lot of
expert witness testimony in cases I
can't resist usually involves some black
has been abused by the police and Sewer
sucks it up and sues the police and I
generally become their principal witness
against the police not a very popular
thing to do and frankly another thing I
enjoy doing but but there were so many
egregious abuses being perpetrated by
the police here in there although in the
main they do a wonderful job in my view
that thought I have found that suing the
police is one of the effective ways of
reforming the police there are really
only four ways to reform the police from
abusing their authority in terms of
brutality corruption racism racial
profiling there are four ways one if you
have a tough and determined police chief
who is a reformer like Pat Murphy in New
York City from around October 1970 to
May of 1973
so tough and determined police chief is
the number one way to do it
number two the FBI investigations the
Justice Department has the authority to
investigate police wrongdoing and when
they finally suck it up and do it they
do a very good job it's hard to get them
to do it in New York for example they
did it on the Louima case the Abner
Louima case fellow who had a opposed dug
up his rectum and then struck in the
mouth with it but they didn't do it in
the Diallo case in the case where they
got cops fired 41 shots and and killed
the amadou diallo they did not so tough
police chief the FBI investigations
that's - suing a civil suit is a good
way to reform the police it captures
their attention in the Abner Louima case
the settlement was eight million dollars
that's one dollar for every man woman
and child in the city of New York so
that they begin to think well gee it's
coming out of my pocket it's kind of
hidden taxation someday some smart
politician is going to awaken to the
fact that that the all these civil suits
are a hidden tax because the cops don't
pay the civil suits the citizen spends
so that's three police chief
FBI civil suits and then of course the
one the one powerful institution in our
society that is probably the key to
their democratic system and the most
valuable single institution what Thomas
Jefferson called the newspapers Thomas
Jefferson said if I had to live with
newspapers and no government or a
government and no newspapers I would
choose newspapers than no government I
feel the same way I think that the media
much maligned greatly abused there isn't
a political figure in America who is not
full of self-pity who's not wallowing in
some grief and anguish over the abuse he
or she is getting from the media the
reality is that the American media is
the most
important institution in the democracy
and and and key to our liberties and we
are the best informed people the world
has never seen because of it we
certainly there's an awful lot of trash
and pornography but there's also a lot
of exalted and erudite classical stuff
so those four ways are the ways that a
police agency can be reformed civilian
review boards don't work everybody loves
them everybody talks about them there
isn't a single one anywhere in America
that works there is just don't work and
and and I speak to these issues in the
book so I spent 36 years in the police
world came away loving the police
thinking that they do wonderful stuff
they're heroic they're noble but they
also because they have a tremendous
amount of power attempted to abuse that
power and and the temptation often
proves irresistible and and and and you
get egregious acts of police abuse and
and corruption
they also the police carry out the
Mandate of the overclass we don't like
to talk about class in America but we
have class we have two classes we have
the other class that we have the end of
class the over class is mostly white
powerful property-owning well-off good
shape educated the underclass tends to
be excluded poor black uneducated it's
good and and without a job and
unemployable people often say to me well
gee you came to this country as an
immigrant and you made it why can't
blacks make it in America and what
everybody forgets is that when I came to
America I was rich I just didn't have
any cash but we had a family together
we had a religion we had a culture we
had a vision we all stayed together I
had a name that was that that I knew
where he came from so we landed on here
so the opportunities went to
who works strong the sweat is a stain
and never had to worry about race and
made it wears blacks have been here for
two or actually three hundred and eighty
two years they first arrived in August
of 1619 slave ship Jamestown Virginia
they had two hundred forty four years of
slavery slavery was replaced by Jim Crow
ISM when when the North abandoned the
idea of reconstructing the South and
decided that they would go for the
Democratic vote instead but with a
capital D Democratic and and allow the
the southern states to pass a series of
laws segregating toilets water fountain
schools everything buses everything you
can think of theaters movies so they had
a hundred years of Jim Crow and then you
get a little blast of light in the early
60s when a hope suddenly was animated by
the by the civil rights movement and
then that that followed by prison the
way we deal with the black community
today is we imprison it's males one out
of every three black males in America is
under some form of Criminal Justice
control whether it's parole probation
prison or whatever so we have gone from
slavery to Jim Crow to a brief few
seconds of civil rights enthusiasm to
prison which has been going on now since
the mid 60s around 1965 as a consequence
we now have a record number of people in
prison
two million half of whom are blacks and
and one out of every three black males
on probation parole or prison and and
and that's what we do now crime is
declining and people say well gee maybe
imprisoning blacks because a lot of
street crime is committed by blacks for
reasons that will become clear in a
moment or maybe maybe it works but the
reality is the most of the people we
have in prison are there for nonviolent
offenses they're there for drug offenses
the only area of policing that is still
be very proactively and energetically
pursued and the reason why blacks are
forced into lives of crime is the
oppressor the the white over class makes
conditions of life so intolerable for
the blacks that the males cannot get
education can I get jobs they were
normally unemployed at the rate of the
three times the rate of white males
can't get jobs can't get educators they
turn to escape they need to escape this
horrible oppression and they do this by
alcohol and drugs and crime and violence
and rioting now the blacks don't want to
admit that that the street crime is
overwhelmingly and preponderantly the
action of black males and whites are
certainly not going to admit that they
have created such horrifying conditions
that criminality becomes inevitable so
instead we ignore the issue go on
arresting those people and and have a
great time without ever really
addressing the issue of social racial or
economic justice the rich getting to
rich the poor to poor blacks ghettoized
so we see a couple of blacks in public
office or we see them on the television
and we begin to to to feel well gee
they're beginning to make it but the
statistics the 2000 census demonstrated
there is a widening chasm between the
white and the blacks in terms of
property income salaries education the
only positive statistic relating to
blacks in America currently is that was
in 1995 about 35 percent of black kids
was growing up in two-parent families
now it's as close to 40 percent so it's
down from around 35 percent to 40 which
is an improvement so why is crime
declining so dramatically New York City
when I became a cop in 1953 was having
about a murder a day population of 8
million and by 1992 was having about 6
they had gone from one-a-day to six and
it wasn't the murder capital of America
and the population was seven million but
they forgot to count about a million
Somali taxi drivers that were slipping
between the cracks and avoiding the
census so in reality in 1992 New York
had a population of 8 million really 7
million officially 1 million illegal
aliens 8 in 1953 had 8 million one
murder a day in 1953 6 a day in 1992
what had happened is I think that the
euphoria and the enthusiasm loosed by
the hope behind the civil rights
movement was - so cruelly that by 1968
with the assassinations of Kennedy and
Martin Luther King jr. which was a
watershed year in American history 1968
we had a kind of Commission report
saying that the Society was drawing
further and further apart
we had rioting we had assassinations we
had the the Vietnam War we had a seminal
election in which Hubert Humphrey lost
the to Richard Nixon and launched the
nation on on a mild strim of of racist
violence against blacks in response to
which they led lives of utter
hopelessness but I think that the
reasons behind the decline in crime
since 1992 and and I only used New York
illustratively because this happen all
across the nation that is that there was
a very sharp drop in crime from 1995
peaked around 92 and then it be a sharp
drop to the present time I think it is
due to a number of factors one we can
now say that the crack epidemic actually
peaked around 1985 and then it began to
decline then the burgeoning economy
actually began to hire blacks even as a
last resort black males began to find
jobs
and and we had and maybe imprisonment
did a little good I really don't think
that the police are very relevant to the
issue of crime rates but then there is a
hidden kicker in all of this that nobody
wants to discuss in which I first wrote
about in 1991 ten years ago and it's roe
v-- wade if we have a million abortions
a year roughly and 250,000 of those
abortion or so maybe more or two
impoverished ignorant on welfare teenage
mothers who normally give birth to what
a quality at-risk population that is no
male president welfare lack of education
lack of hope if we have those young
women experiencing abortions of the rate
of two hundred and fifty thousand and
one and half of those are going to be
males which is where you know when
criminologist speak of the at-risk
population they're talking about black
males eight about fifteen to twenty five
twenty eight that's really what they're
talking about who are uneducated and it
poor and on welfare drugs and so on
that's the at-risk population was since
nineteen seventy three in America roe
v-- wade and earlier in some states that
adopted abortion laws before them around
1970 71 72 there is now in a statistical
correlation between the decline in the
add risk male population in that age
group at risk group and the decline in
crime that will be reversed because the
demographics begin to work against us in
there in another few years as Hartford
Connecticut has just found out but but
the reality is that that it's macro
social and economic forces that are at
work that that that either will drive
the crime rate up or down if you have a
adjust society that makes it rich a
little less rich its poor a little less
poor really educates people gives them
jobs gives them hope crime begins to
decline no matter how many cops you have
whereas if you if you do the opposite
crime the conditions of the underclass
become so intolerable that they begin to
act up and and therein there is no
advanced industrial society that does
less for its poor than America in a way
it's that's one of the reasons why we
are so successful because we we have
really a kind of Darwinian capitalism
that where we can fire people hire
people whereas in Europe you can't you
can't find people easily in Europe and
and and and so and they have all kinds
of benefits unemployment benefits health
benefits education benefits or kaisers
salary benefits that you don't have in
America or or in a very diminished State
so the reality is that that it is
possible to to reach the the overclass
in America much more easily than
anywhere else but it's also easier to
get into the underclass and the problems
attendant upon the the the violence in
the streets so that's what I think
crime is declining in America because of
all of these factors and they're not
gonna work in our favor forever sooner
or later they begin to work against this
new drugs come along there's this one
coming out now oxy Condit oxy candid I
think it's called that there's another
one ecstasy so no drugs are coming along
that are beginning to entice our people
into a drug culture and more violence
and of course there is one drug that
nobody wants to talk about that is very
very at the very core of violence in
American that's alcohol if you go to
prison and you talk to the prisoners
there you will see whatever what are the
conditions that they're all males that's
number one
half of them are black they all they're
a semi-literate or uneducated hopeless
employment to unemployment situations
and and the overwhelming majority were
involved in alcohol to the degree that
it that it began to affect their
functioning and and contribute to the
the negative aspects of their lives now
all of these things are things that the
police have to deal with all the time
they deal with the results of the
societal and racism or societal
injustice and and they can't really talk
about it because you know you can't go
around saying we remain on the payroll
in order to keep those people in their
place and out of sight and and we are
really here to enforce the subliminal
messages of a racist society as well as
the laws that are clearly enunciated and
explicitly written well they can't admit
that so they they become a culture unto
themselves the police and they become
it's a hermetically sealed Atlantis and
the reason I wrote this book was to try
to penetrate into that Atlantis to it to
to sort of reveal to the to the reader
what's going on here how is it that I
why don't I understand it in this very
city that Providence you and I speak of
that in the book we had a situation
where a black male is in a restaurant
eating with his family and he sees a a
man with a gun on the sidewalk and eat
the black male as a police officer takes
his gun out comes outside to her to help
and a shot dead by the responding police
well there's no doubt that the police
were all acting in good faith they they
saw a black man and the me immediately
assumed that he was a criminal
well that tells you something about our
racist society if he had been white with
a gun I think they would have waited a
few minutes I think they waited waited
that split-second that would have made
the difference between life and death
so even tragedies that that appeared to
be unavoidable or in fact avoidable
because ray erases at the core of it
race is the most serious problem the
nation faces and and one that simply
refuses to face and and the police have
to cope with the violence and the
unhappiness and the addictions that that
race produces because of the lack of
education and the lack of hope and the
lack of progress of most blacks because
now a three hundred eighty two years
later we still find them outside looking
in so that's what it's about this is
actually police unbound is the eighth
book that I've written and quite frankly
I thought enough was enough I had
written seven books some of them had
proved miraculous cures for insomnia and
and and there's conventions of
insomniacs would throw them into corners
as if they were some kind of sacred
relics because they have achieved such
peace and tranquility as a consequence
of my labors they had a soporific effect
upon an entire generation so I decided
after seven failures the heck with it
I'm not gonna write a book unless a
publisher calls and asked me to write a
book now that's like saying I'm never
gonna go on any more dates unless cindy
crawford calls well miraculously Cindy
Crawford did call and asked me to write
a book that isn't in the form of an ugly
publisher Prometheus and that breach to
the title Prometheus Bound to Iraq
because he brought fire to man for me he
is the publisher police unbound so
Prometheus Bound police unbound that's
the connection and I wrote this book
just wanna tell the the sort of indicate
to the reader
you look at a story and you think you
understand it PS you don't I'll give you
an example add water versus Vistal ariga
there's a case went to the Supreme Court
and everybody will say gee I never heard
of it
I never but everybody has heard of it
add water is the woman who refused to
put her children in the seat belt and
herself in a seat belt and was led off
by the police and handcuffs
held for hours finally with until she
made $300 in bail finally went to court
and she was fined $50 for each of her
little children who were not wearing
seatbelts now her story was that she was
looking for something they had lost the
dog or an elephant or a cat or something
and and they were driving very very
slowly
and they had to in order to look they
couldn't wear the seatbelt and and the
police officers just so merrily let them
let her away in handcuffs the children
were left spending $300 in bail finally
two $50 fines as she appealed it so the
first court said the cop was right
the it went the court of appeals held 11
to nothing against her and she appealed
it to the Supreme Court the Supreme
Court and one of those amazing events
there were four people on the Supreme
Court who vote for the police no matter
what the police do doesn't matter
Clarence Thomas Antonin Scalia William
Rehnquist and and John William Kennedy
those warm so they're gonna vote for the
for the cop no matter what but this time
it was a New Englander who saved them
David Souter who normally votes on the
other side of every question and who
knows the law and who was an attorney
general and who has some wisdom as
opposed to the other four but wrote the
decision that said the cop was right and
the other four joined in and
was a five-to-four decision Sandia
Center O'Connor was outraged well folks
the cop was right there was an
outrageous case it was a stupid case it
was nuts but whenever you get a citation
for a traffic violation you were given
that citation in lieu of arrest which
means the cop always has the opportunity
to arrest you if he or she wants to they
have that choice always and if the
Supreme Court had held if Sudha had not
brought some wisdom to this event it
would have thrown out the the
underpinning behind every traffic
citation in America just an absurd idea
and it shows you know people look at
that case and they say oh my god that's
how gracious that's crazy
yes the woman failed the attitude test
it is not safe to question the authority
of the police if you are involved in a
traffic event with the police the send a
more sensible thing to do is to be
obsequious to be fawning to be servile
to be respectful and when you fail the
attitude test and you become truculent
and defiant you're going to get into
trouble and that's what happened to this
woman but also happens to a lot of black
males who feel the necessity to assert
their manhood they are suddenly
challenged am i a man or a mouse
am I gonna back down before this
authority figure I've had it I've
suffered long enough I'm gonna stand on
my hind legs and protest wrong bad
mistake a lot of black males get into an
awful lot of grief because of it so
that's the case where where you look at
the facts that you think you get it as a
citizen you don't it's just the reverse
the D amadou diallo shooting 41 shots 19
hit him killed him what what happened
there why did the case fail did they
want all the cops were acquitted well
they were indicted for murder
they didn't commit murder the reverend
al sharpton said those cops are
murderers
so the District Attorney of the Bronx
a black official who was trying to curry
favor with the electorate so I said okay
that's that's what the black community
wants i'll indict them for murder
you can indict a ham sandwich the
question is can you convict it that's
the tough question but you can indict a
ham sandwich if you want to of course
grand juries are just the the
instruments of the prosecutor so he
indicted them for murder
a a defense attorneys dream all he had
to do was prove they didn't commit
murder that they had not deliberately
set out premeditatedly to kill him and
they were off the hook did they commit a
crime very likely they committed
probably manslaughter the unintentional
killing of one human being by another
wrongfully what makes it wrong well
Diallo was not around well he made a
menacing motion that's not enough to
satisfy the law the more requires deadly
force the threat of death it has to be
viable there has to be real
somebody reaching you for a calm or or a
wallet is not deadly force so I think we
have to begin to make that distinction
and again I try to deal with that with
that distinction in the book the book is
is actually what I you know most police
memoirs are how I righted the ship of
state what a wonder what a lucky country
to have had my ear services well that's
not what this is about this book is
about my mistakes and a review of my
mistakes and try to analyze what I
learned from those mistakes
what kind of important lessons
principles emanated from them freak for
example in 1968 we had a sit-in a
Columbia University the students said in
a Columbia University because they were
trying to prevent the college from
building a gymnasium in parkland that
was the heart of the black community and
and these students were
fighting to keep Columbia University
from building
well my attitude and the attitude of
everyone was what a bunch of ink racy
snotty rich kids they are they are up
there in the clouds ethereal II here we
are in the trenches dealing with
horrifying reality and here they are
floating route into outer space these
are space shots and we got we have to
teach him a lesson and they're a bunch
of ingrates
and sure enough we busted in arrested
everybody there was gas and workings
about well I had a sit-in and I was part
of the of that horrible tragedy I about
about eight years after that 1970s five
or six seventy five seven years after
that 1975 I had sevens in the Bronx at
Lehman College and hostes College where
students were sitting in over hiding
tuition and again I was and I speak
about it in the book I was being pressed
do something about it was an or gonna
end there's chaos and I thought those
kids have as much of an interest in the
institution as the president of the
institution just as the kids in Columbia
they were those kids were the only ones
who had a sense of racial justice the
rest of us didn't they were right and we
were wrong as the kids at Harvard were
right last year when they said in to
trying to get economic justice for the
janitorial help and everybody was trying
to figure out how to get them out and
gas them and arrest them and fortunately
cooler heads prevailed and and it seemed
to have been managed sensibly that's how
true ISM but those kids were doing is
demonstrating the importance of
principle they were risking their
liberty and their safety in in Columbia
University for the sake of preserving a
part land for the black community in
hostas and Lehman College they were
trying to preserve lower tuition fees
for black and Hispanic students at
Harvard they were trying out true istic
ly and selflessly to
promote the interests of humble
janitorial workers and cleaners I think
that's that's one of the great lessons
that I learned from my mistakes the
Columbia bust of 1968 was a ghastly
blunder and again with Torque 68 so much
happened in 1968 and I learned from that
blunder and talked about it so every
warned of every anecdote in a sense is
an analysis instead of my many triumphs
and all the wonderful things that I did
it is a review of my many mistakes and
stupidities and blundering and and what
I learned from them Napoleon Bonaparte
was once asked which soldiers make the
best generals and he said lucky ones
well I believe I subscribe to that idea
I think I was very lucky to have had 36
years in the police world and and made
it through after all the horrifying
stupid mistakes that I made one after
another ghastly stuff many of which are
recounted in this book not all I
couldn't afford to it was list them all
first it would be a much thicker book
and secondly I'd be in prison or all
likelihood so I better watch myself
but but the reality is that that I try
to reveal the Atlantis the secret world
of the police and and and and in the
process the political world surrounding
it because there is no more political
world and the world of the police we
like to think that the police are free
of politics but that's the greatest
absurdity going the reality is that
every act of government is a political
act and and and the police are very
heavily involved in politics what we
need to do is to keep the police free of
partisan politics not favoring the
Republicans over the Democrats or a
candidate X of a candidate B forget it
but but every act of government has to
be a political act so I try to speak to
that but Gunnar Myrdal and is in his
wonderful
seminal work an American dilemma 1941
sixty years ago said America's greatest
difficulty is the Negro problem I want
to echo that statement sixty years later
for my experience in public life from 36
years in policing from where you're
witnessing this great country of ours
that I love no one loves America more
than an immigrant who has been raised to
positions of power and wealth we love
this country in a way that all these
jingoist patriots would never dream of
loving it we love this country but
America has got to come to terms with
the race question and it has to dispense
justice and I say and if a black said
this we don't say oh well what can you
expect but why do I say it I'm probably
as much of a racist as anybody I mean
you can't grow up in this society and
not be a racist you have to be you I'm
very conscious of whether people are
white or black but I say it because I
want to I would like to help America
come to its senses
it's the oppressor as much the oppressed
suffer visibly there in prison they're
excluded they're beaten up they're not
educated they're given drugs and alcohol
okay but the oppressor suffers too the
Nazis were corrupted and brutalized and
turned into horrible monsters because
they they were permitted to continue
their crimes and encourage them until to
the point where they began to think that
the things they were doing we're
perfectly normal and perfectly right I
mean that we ought to exterminate these
inferior people that we call Slavs and
gypsies and Jews that's great and and in
no time at all everybody was saying
hurrah the especially says for the
little time the country seems to be
ready in in a successful direction
militarily if nothing else but it's
morality that matters a life unexamined
is not worth living in the final
analysis of I learned nothing it is the
principles
morality matters do the right thing
character matters and that's what how
and as a nation our character is not
doing well and it needs to do better and
there's no better opportunity than to
begin to talk about the race question
now I don't I don't want to prescribe
the solutions the solutions are easy you
could just say let's do the scandinavian
model attack to the rich at a higher
rate give the poor big a break educate
more people let's try to be a more just
society but that's a prescription
prescriptions are for demagogues what we
need to do is the Socratic torture
method examining ourselves talking about
talking about our our nation discussing
the problems is race the biggest problem
that America faces or my crazy that's
the question we ought to be deciding and
what does it mean are we really a racist
society well when the police do racial
profiling they prove that we are a
racist society because racial profiling
simply means you do a statistical
analysis who is the likeliest person to
commit a crime in our society well
that's easy an impoverished uneducated
unemployed black male who does drugs and
alcohol that's who's gonna okay so the
next time you see a black male and if
he's a young a young male and he's
driving a Rolls Royce
he's obviously committing a crime let's
stop him that's illegal you need four
things to stop somebody on the street in
the video behind the wheel of a car on
the street you need articulable grounds
or you need probable cause you need some
evidence so there's an easy way to stop
racial profiling in America just ask the
cops to that why do they you stop this
black now or because he's black well the
Constitution doesn't allow that there's
a Fourth Amendment you cannot undertake
our reasonable searches and seizures
except upon probable cause what was the
probable cause so the reality is that
racial profiling is easy to stop the
underlying problem of racism is
the question is simply going to pop up
somewhere else in another form and and
if you eliminated racial profiling
tomorrow like that something else would
take its place and and you would you
would have you would not have moved one
inch forward we need to debate the race
issue and and and just finally a lot of
police chiefs in America are now
trotting out all their programs in
telling you what a wonderful job they've
done and now they have eliminated crime
in our society and violence that's not
what happened
there are there macro forces at work
economic social racial at work that the
police have nothing to do with for the
nine years that I was chief of police in
Minneapolis I ran the most aggressive
Police Department in America it is only
common sense to think does anybody think
the founding fathers were a bunch of
liberal wimp O's who did not want law
and order I mean that's an absurdity
they tolerated slavery forever sake the
United States Constitution is a law in
order document it permits you to be very
aggressive in controlling crime you can
have a very tough police department and
continue to observe the United States
Constitution you can do decoys you know
people who go out outfit it like victims
little old ladies drunken guys get
mugged you can do stakeouts put cops
behind hiding behind the counter and
when robbers come in they arrest those
should the robbers you can do a stings
open up a storefront and you have people
come in and sell their stolen television
sets and and ultimately arrest them or
for receiving stolen property so you can
do a lot of stuff that is totally legal
in a in in the 1980s I was teaching
Minneapolis cops to do choke holds long
after the George Patton of American
policing Daryl gates in Los Angeles have
had to abandon them because of political
pressures my attitude was if it's
illegal make it illegal and I'll stop
doing it just as if if you can
a citation in lieu of arrests anymore
change them all you can have the Supreme
Court change it they can change it but
the legislature can change it so help me
the United States Congress can pass the
law saying citations were no longer the
issue in lieu of arrest you would take a
citation and if you don't want to take
it we'll get you somewhere else
but we're not going to arrest you okay
that would be perfectly all right
there's nothing in the Constitution that
mandates it so but the reality is that
that you've got you've you've got to
decide what it what kind of a society
you want to construct and why and and
and the notion of racial profiling it's
easy to dismiss but any aggressive
street crime program the seeks to attack
violence in the streets muggings
robberies burglaries rapes assaults any
program is going to wind up with a
disproportionate percentage of black
males amongst the people arrested and
the reason we that is true it's because
it is a racist society so if I had any
message for the nation he says I have
been privileged in the course of my life
to be given platforms where I have an
opportunity to speak to large numbers of
people if I had any message it is let's
talk about race let's talk about social
justice let's talk about racial justice
and let's talk about economic justice
that's what this book is about and I
hope my life so thanks for listening and
happy to deal with any questions anybody
has occurs to me from
a modest position of having taught
police in Manhattan and Brooklyn and
that is on the management level we've
tried civilian review boards and you
refer to that we tried and I sat on a
Rhode Island Commission Providence
Commission rather and I said once to his
honor the mayor why don't we keep the
Commission going as kind of a review
board well that was my mistake because
all he had to hear and one of the Chiefs
was on with me and other citizens and he
dropped the idea and we dissolved so it
seems
if you make any principle valid for the
police there's something wrong with it
and we are now trying as you well know
diversity and recruitment and training I
wonder how long that will last but at
all often I recall taking courses at
John Jay College in criminal justice
neither Hoffer and a few others taught
me and you certainly know and I had a
feeling that I was at dental school
preparing for root canal work because
any of these proposals that we brought
up to the police were negated or diluted
if we were lucky or buried so are you an
optimist no no I'm not I'm a pessimist
but you're a realist I hope so and
everybody thinks they were realist yeah
III take a very pessimistic view of the
future and end of and of our willingness
or ability to control the police I mean
President Bush actually disapproves of
the notion of the FBI investigating the
pool
now that would remove one of the great
investigative pillars so there are two
questions that you raised one was
oversight of the police and thus
desperately needed and very flexing and
weak and the other is minority
recruitment right one of the great
successes in America I was I was a key
figure in attempts to hire both women
and blacks with women I succeeded
wonderfully there plenty of women in the
ranks with blacks I failed miserably we
do not recruit blacks with anything like
the numbers that that we'd like end and
the reason I think it's twofold one is
racism institutional white racism and
two black leaders say so many negative
things about the police that no young
black male ever thinks of becoming a cop
I am hoping that the Lakers Shaquille
O'Neal becomes a Los Angeles cop that
would be wonderful I hope they give him
a million dollars a week and and and put
him into a uniform that would be
wonderful because I'd love to see black
kids relating to someone like them maybe
we ought to draft Michael Jordan into
the police world but yeah you're right I
mean the the notion of oversight and the
notion of a recruitment are two
questions and and the police are
tremendously sensitive to the notion of
of any control any control do you have a
question madam you don't okay it's
alright with me is it okay to applaud oh
thank you thank you thank you for being
here for listening so attentively and
courteously and generously yes like
watching it the notice hasn't gone out
in time it is or it is better to light a
candle than to curse the darkness that's
okay I'm perfectly happy